now if you're bored of seeing me i
wouldn't blame you i've been at sky news
would you believe for 21
years now and i've just been reminded
that it was 12 years ago
in 2009 that i first had the pleasure
the joy the honor of talking to jedward
who were huge at the time and now i get
it but what's different
i hear you say about jedward what is
different
boys it's good to see you again how are
you doing
good to see you he's john i'm edward and
together we are
jedward and it's 2021 it's great to see
you stephen
yes we're so honored to be here on sky
news it's always very
and you may have noticed something all
the viewers we shaved all of our hair
for cancer we raised nearly three
million
with loads of people in ireland the
irish society and it was a monumental
moment for us the first time we've had
our hair like this since
the beginning yes we are rocking the
shane o'connor
do you know what well i've got to say it
suits you both it actually it's a re
it's a really good you look at it it's
like
extra aerodynamic you know yeah cause we
used to do a lot of running and i've
been running a lot recently getting
exercise being in lockdown so yeah it's
been the perfect haircut but i think
like a lot of people
get cancer and who knows what the future
holds for anybody we all got to stay
strong in this lockdown it was just a
sense of community everyone coming
together to raise the money
and i feel the nhs and just different
healthcare different countries
and certain organizations make that
difference with like at night nurses or
anything it doesn't make a difference
for family members because
our mom passed away from cancer was one
of the main factors in 2019
so we definitely had to grow up
ourselves didn't we john
yeah we've always you know been on a
journey and it's good that we're here to
catch up with you steve
but you know what it's it i know it's
it's it's really important to you i mean
losing your mom is is a
is a terrible thing i know we all have
to face it at some point
i i dread the moment i've got to go
through what you two have been through
um but the fact that you can celebrate
her
and and raise money in her name in this
way
she'd be so proud wouldn't she i know
she would be
honestly she was always you know our
biggest fan and she's always supportive
and always wants us to go out there and
you know express ourselves and
never uh be nervous or scared so that's
what we keep doing but i think the
support of everyone kind of feels like
everyone gave us a big hug virtually
because there was a really good sense of
community like when
are from our fans with people in general
i know you're saying that we were hot
back then
we've done your vision twice big brother
twice and we're on sky news today
2021 the best show in the world wow
oh do you know how much we paying you
for this
i want us to sing you a bit of a song
shane o'connor with live from ireland
oh go on then go on soon as you look
like chinese
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing
that should be on you that should be our
new ident music as we call it here we
might we might have to
have to stay on that i'll take it but
how have you been how's it been in the
news over there lately
how's everybody with you i i'm very well
thank you i'm very well i worked i
worked
hello i worked from home on tv
can i just say can i just say you have
both got a bit political in your tweets
over the last 12 months haven't you
what's brought that on
i think it's just good we're in this
time and day to make a stance and i feel
like a lot more people in entertainment
world need to make a stance because
they're at a platform
and it does make a massive difference
especially in the entertainment world
because you're not reaching that
demographic but certain people
aren't watching sky news or cnn or those
other competitors
so yeah i think there's these you gotta
everyone wants to be seen and heard and
it's great that we can
you know be with the fans and be with
the people who are speaking the new
future moving into the future
so i feel sometimes people have these
old beliefs we've got to be open-minded
to everyone else's
um beliefs yeah and i feel like trans
rights matter as well i feel like
there's a lot of different laws that
need to be changed give them rights
in healthcare and that's an ongoing
issue and i feel like
this time last year we were marching in
the black lives matter
uh protest in los angeles because we
were doing them quarantined with tara
reid so
we've done a full 360 and it reaped does
make you feel like you're making a
change and i feel like music
and just your voice in general does make
it a lot more deeper
yeah because you came out an album
called voice of a rebel in 2019
and then the crazy year that we had in
2020 and 2021 still
those uh songs can like uplift you and
you know particularly those dark times
and i know we tweeted about the winston
churchill statue going into pierce
morgan's back garden but we actually
meant
the way they were treating those women
like at the vigil
and the comparison they were protecting
the statue which isn't living and they
were had more priority looking after
that so i just think
priorities need to be in the right areas
when it comes to
policing yeah absolutely you know what
it's it's really good and really nice to
hear
young people because you're still young
compared to me being able to have a
voice on these matters i think it's
really important
it's been great we're out of time but
it's been great to see you boys again
you take care
and the vatican also need to approve of
lgbtq
marriage because your churches are down
they need some life
yes so everyone look after themselves
we'll see you soon in 2022
on tour everyone stay safe and get your
vaccine and stay
epic boys thank you very
much indeed thanks sky news
what'd you say well i i do like him i've
got to be honest i do like